[Music]
good to see you my friend good to see
you as well man that man so so delighted
I know I think this is you been on here
like four times maybe three or four
times but it's been a while maybe like
two years since we sat down and done
this a lot of things happening since
then yes a lot of fun stuff going on
empire-building know in your world I
mean you are just out there crushing it
green print is a new book it's
unbelievable I checked the other day was
number two on Amazon a space that was
occupied by David Goggins just prior you
you guys traded places and that is no
small thing number two of all books on
Amazon for what is essentially a life
style guide and sort of prescriptive
program for adopting a plant-based
approach to your diet and life which is
I mean that's for the for that idea to
occupy the number two spot on Amazon is
insane yeah now it feels absolutely
amazing but I think it's it's really a
testament to the time you know that
we're living in I mean people are just
sick and tired of being sick and tired
yeah it's a people want to change and
they realize that you know the the old
way this obsession with you know
animal-based protein that we've had for
the past 70 years is really not leading
them in the direction that they want to
go it's not helping them achieve their
their goals so it's it's really I think
it's the time couldn't be better and
we've had this conversation yeah you
know plenty of times about how you know
how do you allow people to come into a
space without making it feel like you're
judging them right out the gate right so
from it for me it's always been about
that like let's have a conversation
that's really constructive but but super
inclusive right and that's what we
wanted to create and and the reality is
that whenever you have a conversation
and you start it with like oh it's a
vegan program or it's a vegan lifestyle
people immediately you know they're like
right I'm out I'm out tap you know I
can't do it it's too hard it's too
restrictive it's too expensive it's -
its - its to be
it just feels very finite it feels super
you know defined there's walls it's you
know very judgmental and then you hear
about people going plant-based and then
they start getting beat up or you know
going vegan and they start getting beat
up on social because it's not truly
vegan right they're still wearing
leather or I still did this they get
shamed by because they haven't done it
exactly the way that person would like
them to do it but I think that that no
one benefits from that no right there's
no truly passionate about the
environment you want people to lean more
if you're truly passionate about human
health you want people to lean more if
you are doing it for your own you know
selfish reasons you want people so I
said the end of the day it really is
about allowing people to define it in
the way that works best for them and
Fanning the flames of positive yeah
absolutely for me it's always been you
know I have friends that come up to me
and like man I'm really I'm really
trying this thing and I'm a you know
it's almost like they're coming to me
like I'm not going to approve and right
they're like yeah I'm breakfast and
lunch and almost always dinners an all
week and sometimes I'll do whatever X Y
or Z and I'm like that's amazing and
they're like really
my guess that's that's fantastic you
know look at where you were before look
at the direction that you're headed in
that's massive progress and for me it's
always been about you know progress it's
not about perfection
it's about aggression if you get people
to think more about what they're putting
into their body where it's coming from
to become more conscious about you know
how the food is grown were you know how
its treated if it's an animal and and
you really when you start to connect all
the dots you can't help but to want to
become super passionate about the space
but but you have to allow people to walk
in yeah you have to make them feel okay
and comfortable about taking that leap
not afraid that they will be judged or
that they will fail or be incapable of
living up to some sort of impossible
standard because I think there's this
sensibility that somebody like yourself
or these other kind of icons of this
movement made their transition in a
magical you know leap that was perfect
in every regard and mark
by you know rainbows and unicorns and
there was never a mistake had along the
way and it certainly wasn't my
experience I'm sure it wasn't yours no
that's not the case with anybody I've
met with or worked with or spoken to or
any of the people that perhaps you you
know look up to as as examples or models
of healthy living ya know it's exactly
that really when I decided that I wanted
to do this for myself I thought okay
well I'm gonna move away from animals I
had already ditched dairy and I did
stags and I'm gonna move away from
animals but I was still eating fish and
then one day I woke up and I was like
man I don't know how this feels
something it just clicked right it just
one day you just wake up and it happens
and I was like hmm I'm really trying to
be conscious of what I'm putting into my
body and I'm really thinking about you
know how the animals are treated and
that's why you don't cuz initially it
was just it was all for health reasons
right it was like I saw disease all
around me I see like everyone and my
family either had diabetes or they had
you know heart disease or pretty heart
disease and it's like okay this is not
normal right it it looks like it's
normal but it's really not normal and
it's not well it's been normalized yeah
but but we get used to this standard and
we're just like we accept it for what it
is but I'm not the kind of guy that just
accept things because they are right
like if we did that then I mean imagine
what would you know how we would still
be living in society so we we have to be
able to push we have to be able to to to
stop and say is this right is this best
is it best for me is it best for my
family is it best for our communities is
the best for the world and when I when I
started to lean in I thought to myself
well I'm gonna do this because I don't
want diabetes and I don't want heart
disease and I don't want all of these
all of these other diseases that I see
most of my family members suffering from
and then I started to say wow well not
only is it benefiting me but there's
like this beautiful benefit of the
benefit which is that I'm I'm kind of
like doing something for you know
lessening the suffering of animals and I
thought that this is pretty cool that I
could actually do something good for
myself and I'm also doing something good
for the animals and then I took it one
step further but it had to start
somewhere right
so like as I started to lean in I
decided this is something that I I can't
turn back and then the more I educated
myself and the more I learned and the
more I saw because you have to see to
really understand where like it most
people don't know where their food comes
from it's just on the plate to eat it
and there they go about their day but I
think that it you know it's it's
irresponsible to really live that way
because if you did that then you just
put on any clothes you know without a
care in the world that came from a
sweatshop or used you know or bought any
device without knowing if it was you
know something that was stolen or if it
you know so you have to have there
there's a certain responsibilities that
come with our daily actions and that's
where that's where it really started
with me really coming to terms with the
fact that I had the power to affect
change with my own daily habits right
yeah it's uh it's difficult to come into
that sense of personal responsibility
though because and I want to couch my
words carefully it's important to not
shame people out there who perhaps have
yet to take that leap of responsibility
because we live in a system that is
erected solely to prevent us from making
that connection the system doesn't want
us taking personal responsibility for
those choices they would much rather
have us make our choices based on their
recommendations so you have to be able
to cut through all of that marketing
obfuscation just to see the truth once
you do then you can say oh I do need to
take personal responsibility but there's
a little bit of a journey that has to
take place at least I'm talking about my
own personal experience before you can
even have that kind of dawning
realization because so much money and
effort goes into erecting walls so that
we don't know where our food comes from
and we don't know where our clothes are
made and we just think well if it's in
the store if it's in the grocery store
or if it's in you know at the mall like
it must be okay yeah it should be good
for me yeah but we know better right and
and I mean social media for whatever
it's worth
Pat has has been able to like pull the
veil off of a lot of things around the
world right it's made the world a lot
smaller right so when you look at what's
happening and how information is shared
today and what is available to us
you can't just sit there and say well I
don't know any better I didn't know all
right now we can right now we're now
we're living in a time where we're
really able to see what's going on um
and again it's not it's never been for
me it's never been about shaming
anyone's it's been about looking at it
from a perspective of like wow when I
you know once I know something I want to
share it with people right like if I
find this really great you know
restaurant down the street from your
house I'm like hey have you been to that
spot down the street that's so cool I
went there I mean I don't want to keep
that to myself I want to share that's
that that's the beauty of life is to be
able to share with the people you love
so for me it's always been about how do
I share this in a meaningful way but
without making people feel bad because
when you start to share your knowledge
sometimes you could come across the
wrong way like sometimes people feel
like you're preaching to them or that
you're trying to convert them and the
reality is that I'm just trying to share
information to help people live a
healthier life because I see I see it
I've done this for so many years this is
all I've ever done in my life where like
I've been in this space for 25 plus
years and I and I am very very familiar
with the way people live their lives and
how I mean how much we medicate
ourselves how we have to you know take
something to get up in the morning take
something to get down at night you know
use something to I mean it's just like I
look at and I'm just puzzled and I'm
like two people ever stop to wonder if
they can do better just by living a
little bit differently and when you see
that people take that leap of faith and
they go you know what I'm gonna give it
a try and then they start by adding one
plant-based meal a day or by adding two
plant-based meals a day or by going all
the way in they immediately say oh my
God thank you right like I had no idea
and and obviously you know this you know
from personal experience but there's no
better feeling in the world than to have
someone say to you you helped Nietzsche
you know take control of my life or you
helped me change the way that I was
thinking or living or feeling by just
what I was putting into my body and
there's such profound I mean like
profound impact by you just taking one
extra second to stop and to think is
this best for me and I tell my friends
all the time I'm like man it's really
simple every time you eat you're either
fueling disease or
it's super simple like you have to make
the choice it can't just be an automatic
reaction you know that we continue to
condition ourselves to to just move
around because we we don't want to stop
and take the time or put the effort into
to really consider that we may be able
to truly take agency you know over our
health and not you know delegate it over
to someone else well we think we want
that but also we're terrified by that
prospect because then we are responsible
right and a lot of people perhaps aren't
ready for that yet and I think as much
as social media has done in a positive
way to fuel the flow of information
about this lifestyle and other positive
beneficial ideas for people that are
empowering it also serves to try belies
us you know to place us in our
respective silos and a lot of the
arguments in the food and health space
kind of devolve into virtual virtue
signaling to our own groups it's mo its
most it's not about helping out somebody
else it's about making sure that the
group knows that you're a member in good
standing of that group and it's become
very tricky to have those conversations
online without sounding preachy without
virtue signaling just being neutral and
positive and encouraging because it can
be like this toxic place where
productive dialogue has been thrown out
the window
I see in the health space conversations
that are very similar to what I see in
the political space so is that your
experience or no I think for me it's a
little bit different because I you know
I I stayed a bit away from it right in
that I don't have like you have more of
an arm's length yeah relationship with
all of that yes which is healthy that's
good yeah and and it's you know it's by
design right it's it's I love I'm the
eternal optimist you know I'd love to
see the good and everything so I take
the good out of that like you know it
could be great for finding you know
phenomenal restaurants great hotels you
know cool things to do here there
but if you if you go deep in to it
without understanding who you are or
what it is that you want out of you you
can get really lost I mean it's a
wormhole right so for me it's it's
really understanding that there
shouldn't be any walls and and again
that's the premise of this right it's a
it's not about labeling it it's not
about vegan or not vegan let's just
throw that out the window it's about
understanding that the more you lean
towards plants the more you're gonna
benefit right it's about understanding
that the more you think about what
you're putting into your body and
understand where it's coming from the
healthier you're gonna be the healthier
your family is gonna be because they're
gonna follow your actions right my kids
I have four kids and they do what I do
they don't do what I tell them to do
they do what they see me do right so if
I ate junk food all day and I came home
and said hey guys here are some steamed
carrots what do you think they're gonna
do yeah they'd laugh at me right but so
the reality is that I think that we draw
way too many lines we're constantly
putting ourselves you know to your point
in boxes and little silos and and and
trying to you know create tribes around
anything and everything that we do and
I'm saying we need to get away from that
yeah I we're all one we're all living on
this planet together you know we have a
really great way of always putting lines
around everything oh you're in the vegan
group you're in the group that's
American or you and they're mean it's
like these are all lines that we've
created ourselves like we're the most
advanced species on the planet yet
sometimes you do things that are not so
advanced right like we would never you
would never see that in like in the wild
right but yet we do that on a daily
basis openly to each other and I'm
saying and let's just throw that out the
side and this that's just you know love
more let's judge people less and let's
let people come into it in a way that
makes them feel really empowered because
the truth is that you may think you're
alone but 99% of the time you're not
there's other people that are going
through the same thing you're going
through you have no idea how many people
walk up to me like man I never thought I
could do this because I XYZ and then I
talked to this person and I found out
that they were doing the same thing and
I'm I'm now living you know 90%
plant-based where I'm doing this or I'm
doing that and I found you know what
works best for me and it's only because
I
myself did not feel like I was confined
to that you know standard textbook
definition of what I had to do in order
to be accepted into a certain group or a
certain you know whatever category right
but which really makes no sense right at
the end of the day what is it what is it
all about it's about being healthier
it's about being happier because I think
they go hand in hand
it's about be kinder to each other being
better to the animals and kinder to the
planet and it all stems from what we're
putting into our bodies when I look at
it it's it's a lifestyle that checks all
the boxes so if you are concerned about
the welfare of the planet the welfare of
the animals the manner in which we treat
these other beings that we share the
planet with if you care about your own
personal health if you care about the
health of those that you love this is a
lifestyle that addresses all of those in
an incredibly favorable way and as
somebody whose opinion is the truth will
eventually out we've seen the incredible
explosion and growth of this lifestyle
the adoption rates are massive people
all over the world are are realizing the
benefits of a way of living that you and
I know quite well and I want to
transcend this whole conversation about
groups and tribes and all of that but we
do have to say at the same time that we
are seeing the ascension of this
lifestyle we're also seeing like the
low-carb high-fat movement and now this
carnivore movement that's happening and
I'm sure as a trainer who somebody's
steeped in in Physiology people must
come up to you all the time and say oh I
know you're doing the plant thing but
like I'm I'm getting down with the low
carb high fat thing or I'm doing ketosis
or what do you think about the carnivore
diet so it's interesting that you see
these counter balances and these pop the
rise in popularity of these diets that's
are seemingly quite opposite from the
plant-based approach that that you and I
are all about yeah I have a lot of
thoughts about that you know the for me
the easiest thing is
we've had this protein obsession for if
you look back it's probably like 70
almost 80 years now look at high protein
high animal protein low carbohydrate
call it Atkins
call it caveman call it paleo call it
whatever you call it call it whatever
you want at the end of the day we have
to realize that for me it's really it's
common sense like we can get into the
whole you know academic side of it and
we can get into the research and we
could argue and you know you've got the
guys out there our buddy Joe Khan and
you know all the you know dr. Esselstyn
and the Dean Ornish's but for me it's
like let's not even go that far let's
make it really let's make it about
common sense because I think that most
things in life when you apply common
sense you realize what it is that you're
looking for the answer is right in front
of you right like we have had this
obsession like look at it right for the
past 60 70 years now heart disease is
still the number one killer mm-hmm it's
an a rocket ship to the moon and it's
about to be Pat over passed by cancer
and it's not because heart disease is
slowing down it's because cancer is
moving up that much quicker it's not
working it hasn't worked it's not gonna
work right it's not gonna change right
and when you look at it it's like man it
makes sense something that is good for
me is also good for the animals it's
also good for the planets it's just pure
common sense it just feels right that's
the only one thing we haven't tried so
why not give that a try for just a
little while and cents just found area
for just for just a little while like we
have to try something different
right because if you don't change the
process the outcome will never change
we've got to change the process if we
want to change the outcome like we want
to change heart disease we want to Radek
eight heart disease there's a way to
eradicate heart disease go 100%
plant-based we know it the data show the
data proves it the research proves that
there's no other diet on the planet that
has been proven to not just prevent you
know this but a rest and also reverse
heart disease it's a plan to 100%
plant-based diet dr. Kim Williams said
it best there's two type of
cardiologists there's either vegan
cardiologists are the ones that refused
read the data I mean it's that simple
right so like when you look at it you're
like man I mean we could go back and
forth and bring in a hundred experts on
all you know on both sides and we'd make
the arguments so compelling on both
sides that people would just be dizzy
and that's what's happened there's so
much noise that everyone is confused was
this really right for me well I'll tell
you what what you've done to get you to
where you are today has not worked are
you willing to try something different
because people always come in tell me oh
well you know I was doing the how did
that work out mm-hmm well you know I
lost some weight but then I gained it
back again
oh my cholesterol went up but my X Y Z
mic did you find what you were looking
for no so what are you afraid of try
something different for just a short
period of time and see if it works
because you've got to be willing to do
something different if if you truly want
to change how it is it you're living if
you if you want to take back your health
if you want to reclaim your life you
have to do something different because
if it's not working for you it's it's
like the person that over spends all the
time and then winds up trying to figure
out why they're always living check to
check yeah it's not that you don't make
enough money that you spend too much
money that's the that's the issue
because I know plenty of athletes that
have retired without any money and I
know quite a few you know firefighters
police officers a retire and have a
million bucks in the bank it's not about
what you're making it's about what
you're spending and the same goes for
what you're putting into your body and
how you're living your life if you don't
if you're not happy with the outcome you
got to change the process and a lot of
people are willing to do that because
they don't want to stop to think about
it right it takes work and we've become
so accustomed to delegating everything
right like somebody washes your car or
somebody cleans your house somebody
cleans your clothes somebody cuts your
grass somebody cuts your hair some like
all this is you go to the doctor once a
year and you feel like if they give you
a thumbs up you're good to go and you
just go how is this person that you're
gonna see for five minutes gonna know
more about your health and you know
about yourself and you wake up every
single day and know exactly how you feel
when your elbow hurts if it rains why
your knee you know clicks or what like
there's I'm just saying apply a little
common sense and you will have the
answer to every
it's so simple people don't want to do
the work they do want to delegate it
they want to hire somebody to either do
it for them or tell them what to do as a
trainer you know look the trainers have
their place of course but there's
nothing preventing somebody from going
to the gym by themselves or making that
dietary switch on their own but I think
people really are afraid of being
uncomfortable and that speaks to a
malaise about our society in general you
know a common theme on this podcast is
luck of you if you want to change your
life for the better then you have to be
willing to get uncomfortable and it's
not so scary it's actually empowering
what are you so afraid of people are so
freaked out by a plant-based diet
they're so intimidated by it they they
perceive it as so as so limiting like
you mentioned earlier but I don't see
that same reluctance when it comes to
trying a ketogenic diet which in my
perspective is far more restrictive and
difficult and specific and narrowing
than eating the bounty of plant-based
foods that are available to you wherever
you go yeah well I think it's because
they see it as a quick fix right they
don't think I'm gonna be eating keto for
the rest of my life they think I'm gonna
do this for the next you know cuz we've
because weight loss is really the
motivating factor behind all of them
that's it
and and that's what makes it so
confusing because while while that
shouldn't be it actually should right
because that's what actually gets people
to do and do something yeah a and B Wow
that you may think that it's just you
know something that that that you know
is you know sort of external it is the
first symptom that manifests itself us
at the body right so obesity is you know
two trillion dollar business right so
yes we want people to think about living
a healthier life and and it's attached
you know a very direct correlation to
the weight right but a lot of times what
happens is that we've conditioned people
to believe that the dot that a diet
right the word diet is something you get
on and you get off so like oh I could do
that for whatever two weeks I could do
that for
three weeks but there's been this
there's been this like negative
association to veganism or the
plant-based because of all of the
restrictions for so many years that
people don't fully understand what it
truly means are you could ask a lot of
people like what is your definition of
whatever vegan they don't know yeah one
person will say throwing red paint on a
storefront window and the other person
will say you know growing a garden in
your backyard exactly not wearing the
order in like so so it's you know I
think that it's understanding what it is
what it can do for you what it can do
for your family what it can do for the
planet and what it ultimately does for
the animals and when you when you think
of it that way you can't help but to
stop and say man I can do this one meal
a day and that's that's what I love
about what we created with the green
prints that we created three different
tiers and that we say look if you if you
want to go in one meal a day awesome
that's fantastic you're you're like if
you divide it your day into three meals
that's a 33% improvement who doesn't
want that like boom day one right like
we could do that if you want to go two
meals a day make it happen if you want
to go three meals a day or go all the
way in we could help you so the idea is
that you start somewhere but that you
start because you can't get there if you
don't take that first step and we're
hoping that this will serve as a
beautiful guide to help people take that
first step in the direction of the life
that they truly want to live not just
remain satisfied with a life that
they're living and think well it's just
my genes or I'm not supposed to be that
way or am I supposed to have that or my
dad you know part diseases run in my
family so I guess I'm just next in line
it's really about it empowering people
with the information so that they can do
what they need to do to get where they
want to go
yeah the empowerment piece is huge I
mean I see it as twofold
a momentum creating momentum and
momentum creates a cascading
acceleration of this sense of
empowerment and I think when you kind of
scale up and look at our society from
10,000 feet it's pretty clear that that
in general we feel very disempowered
feel like our vote doesn't count who you
know who am I to have an opinion I can't
make a difference I'm just trying to pay
my bills like why even cast your ballots
it doesn't matter anyway
and when you can connect that individual
with that sense of empowerment through
those choices that they're making every
day three times a day about what ends up
on their plate
it really is empowering because it
actually does make a difference yeah if
you go to the grocery store or to the
restaurant and you say you know what I'm
not gonna get that dairy product or that
animal product this the downstream
impact of that decision is significant
and it's real and it feels good to say
you know what I did something that was
right for myself it was right for the
environment and I'm just not gonna
participate in this system that's trying
to prevent me from understanding how it
actually goes down and it involves the
suffering and slaughter of all these
animals that I've now found out I don't
need to be healthy in fact that's moving
me in the direction opposite from my
health goals yeah and and these small
actions you know the they're compounding
over time and it's not just your actions
but it's the actions of everyone else
but I think you hit on something super
powerful there because what happens is
when people throw their hands up and
they're like well it doesn't matter my
vote doesn't count they wind up just
moving around without really putting a
lot of thought you know active in your
life yeah it's almost like just walking
around with blinders are not really
truly understanding you know the power
that you have as an individual to make a
difference right like when you start in
and and it starts with something as
small as we vote every single day like
you complain about your vote not
counting you vote every single day with
your dollars with your money you're
voting every single time you go
somewhere you're either saying give me
more of this or give me more of that but
you're not thinking about it it's just
happening and you could sit during this
like the world that I agree with and
that I want to see yeah or you could do
something about it I'm all about let's
do something about it let's not just
talk about it let's be about it let's
let's put this money to work I'm the
first that will say let's go out and buy
organic produce because when you buy
more organic
there will be more produce that's
organic because guess what organic
produce needs less to grow than
non-organic but the non-organic is less
expensive because we make more of it
because we've gotten to the pole we've
got lazy right so if you think about how
the conventional produce started to
really come about is by understanding
that people just got tired of raising
crops that would you know need more
tending or need more you know watching
after because there was bugs or there
was and and so we got to a point where
we just became so accustomed to it being
conventional that we're okay with that
now and if you're okay with it then
that's fine but I'm I'm thinking like I
want to put my money to work I want to
put my money in a in a place where it's
gonna feed my health it's gonna fuel me
with what I'm looking for and when you
do that you're actively changing the
landscape you're doing something to
change the space that we're living in
and you're right we we all have to do
that because if we do that as a
collective everything changes
from the suffering of animals to the
quality of the food that's in front of
us to the food we can restaurants you're
like oh I you know I go i whatever I go
to a fast food restaurants because it's
all there is well that's all there ever
will be if that's all you arrive shoes
right and meanwhile fast food chains are
adopting plant based options Karl jr.
now has the beyond meat burger and I
think that's something to be celebrated
these organizations are not going away
they're not going away overnight now we
need to you know celebrate movement in a
positive direction within the system
disruption of the system from within and
the fact that you can get a vegan burger
out of fast food chain is a massive move
forward ya know I I couldn't agree more
and I've always been of the mind set
that I don't believe that these big
corporations are trying to help hurt us
I really don't just responding to market
that's it that's it if everybody goes
into Carl's jr. and everybody orders
that beyond meat burger they're gonna
make more of that they're gonna they're
gonna create more options for that
they're gonna crowd out that it's real
beef without a doubt this is how you win
these you know five thousand ten
thousand twenty thousand or fast food
restaurants that are chains are
are not going anywhere they're not
they're not going to disappear overnight
because we stopped going to them what's
going to happen is you say oh wait
people are not coming as often as they
used to what's happening well oh the
industry is moving towards plant-based
well let's offer more plant-based
options and that's exactly what's
happening right there they're looking
for profits they're looking for
profitability we have to guide them in
the direction that we want them to go
but we can't expect for them to do that
if we continue to to to basically buy
into their standard we have to change
the standard from the outside and we
have to do that by voting with our
dollars by saying no we're not gonna do
that we're not gonna buy that we're not
gonna buy junk because we know and we
understand what is what it takes to put
that together but more importantly the
effects that it has on my health your
health and my family and the health of
our communities and then more over the
planet so when you start to do that
everything changes and I think that
we've hit a really beautiful tipping
point that it's all coming together in a
really beautiful way because when you
see that hitting fast food when you look
at the you know the amount of organic
produce that you know Walmart is selling
and when you look at the amount of you
know plant-based options that there are
today compared to what there was you
know five years ago let alone ten years
ago you understand the power and the
impact that this has and it's just it's
growing by the day you know I think we
just need to continue to guide people so
they can continue to vote in the right
direction
yeah I mean even in the last year it's
exploded it's enough and it may sound
daunting and idealistic but I was just
in the grocery store two days ago and
it's I was struck by the dairy aisle a
couple years ago well ten years ago it
would be all dairy and then maybe like
one brand of soy milk five years ago all
right some almond milk some you know
maybe soy milk or rice milk but what I
saw two days ago was an aisle that was
about 75 feet long and well over 2/3 of
it was plant-based milk options and then
the small corner of it was dairy so
that is a massive change from even I
don't think that would have been the
case even a year ago yeah see the
proliferation of these options and
varieties doing well enough that they're
gonna Aki I mean that shelf space at
grocery stores there's a lot of money
and science that goes into what ends you
know this as somebody who's in consumer
products like it's not random
no that's that way because that's what's
selling and that's what's working and
that's what's most profitable for that
organization yeah that's what we're
asking for and I think that most of the
big brands are well aware of it you see
the acquisitions you see them buying
into you know the smaller brands that
are offering plant-based options and the
economists you know named 2019 the year
of the vegan and if you saw the art yeah
and you look at all of the trends in
natural food products or the natural
markets or even the you know big box and
it's the biggest most rapidly growing
sector is plant-based which is to me
it's fascinating and it's an amazing
it's a really amazing time to be alive
because of what's happening in the
industry but it's also a time where we
have to be super aware and and empower
ourselves with the information so that
we don't fall prey to to junk packaged
as yeah it's a yeah say this all the
time it's never been easier to be a junk
food vegan to delude yourself and tea at
all into this idea that you're eating
healthy when you're actually just eating
a bunch of processed junk you may be
doing better
but you're neither for the planet better
the animal is not better for your
personal no so and then I think that
people get confused there and they're
like well at least I'm not and they will
wouldn't you rather do something that
benefits the entire you know the whole
like a triangle that they like do
something that's good for you that's
good for the community it's good for the
animals it's good for the planets
because yeah we could all live on nachos
and you know vegan melted cheese but the
reality is that wouldn't be so healthy
for us I don't think a lot would change
maybe some things have changed but not a
lot so it's really about yes celebrating
the growth of the space but also
understanding that with that growth come
a few you know temptations
in the wrong direction because the big
brands are obviously going to take
advantage of the explosion in the space
and they can call anything now vegan or
anything plant-based as long as it's you
know you know not produced with where
any of the animal by-products so and we
have to be careful but at the same time
it's a really exciting time because if
you want to indulge you can indulge and
never feel like you're you know like
you're going backwards so it's kind of
cool well listen Marco I get all this
plant-based thing I know you you're a
nice guy you seem cool but like you
don't get like I'm an athlete like I I
need my gains in the gym you know I just
don't think this lifestyles for me buddy
yeah you know fortunate for me and for
you there are everyday I see and hear
about new athletes elite athletes coming
out that they're on a plant-based diet
or that that's their secret weapon or
that it has been for quite some time and
you know we see guys like Lewis Hamilton
we see guys like Tom Brady you know we
see guys like you know
Kyrie I mean there's just so many really
amazing athletes that are living their
best life that are 100% plant-based
right that we know without a shadow of a
doubt and and don't just don't just take
it for you know for what is said or
because these three athletes look at the
academic side of it look at the research
right look at how much protein we need
to survive and how much more protein
we're taking in and what protein what
animal protein does to the body and the
inflammatory reaction that the body has
to animal protein and look at the
elevated risk factors for the heart
disease and the diabetes and the obesity
and when you look at performance and you
look at recovery you know one of the
quickest ways to recover faster is to
mitigate some of that inflammatory
response right so if you want to train
harder if you want to be able to recover
faster without a shadow of a doubt the
plant-based diet is head and shoulders
above any other diet on the planet so
again luckily for us we now have these
beautiful examples that we didn't have
maybe five years ago where people are
like yeah
but does it really work cuz I've never
really seen a professional athlete at
their you know highest level highest of
the high there there now like used to
have like this one equestrian that was
the vegan or this one you know it's new
it hasn't and in fairness to ask an
athlete hey listen you should adopt a
plant-based diet when this guy's like
training for the Olympics or he's trying
to go pro like that's a I mean that's a
risky proposition for somebody whose
entire life is ahead of them and what's
on the line is either making it or not
making it getting on that podium or you
know getting the contract and you're
telling them look everything you've been
taught about diet your whole life might
be wrong and you should go this way like
hats off to the person who actually says
okay I'm gonna try that and I don't
begrudge the athlete who says yeah I
don't know I'm gonna I'm gonna do what
and you know these 99 other people are
telling me to do and I think that's one
of the reasons why it's taking a little
bit longer for us to see athletes at the
very highest level who are performing on
a plant-based diet yeah you're you're
you're so right but at the same time
this is another one of those areas where
I say just apply a little bit of common
sense because when you look at the most
powerful animals on the planet they're
plant-based right like when you look at
gorillas elephants rhinos cows I mean
like think about it really every buck to
the common sense thing use common sense
and just think about it like so many
people tell me well but you know aren't
I gonna be missing I'm like when was the
last time you heard someone had was
hospitalized because I had a protein
deficiency I have never heard of that in
my life I've been in the space my entire
adult career never heard of that I've
never heard of I have heard of heart
disease which is not a which is the
exact opposite of approach animal
protein deficiency right I have heard of
tons of diabetes I have heard of
dementia stroke Alzheimer's and a bunch
of other you know inflammatory diseases
I have never heard of someone being
protein deficient I have heard of people
not having enough
fiber in their diet I mean it's an 80
billion dollar business constipation and
it's and it exists because we don't eat
enough plants right so it's fiber
deficient we're not protein deficient
protein deficiency to be protein
deficient you have to literally starve
yourself you have to not eat because all
plants have protein and that's the thing
that most people don't realize is that
all plants have protein all plants have
at least 14 percent protein all all
plants everything from blueberry to spin
it to a you know a macadamia nut
everything has protein in it so if you
if you consume forget about the math
don't do any math if you consume the
right amount of calories during the day
on a hundred percent whole food
plant-based diet you will have more than
sufficient protein you will not be
deficient in protein you don't have to
go backwards and be like how many you
know grams per kilogram of but you don't
have to do any of that right it's done
it's it's almost like nature rigged it
oh really it's like finding a really
cool packaging for fruit that doesn't
like it yeah a banana comes perfectly
packaged you know like you don't need to
put cellophane around it right like you
know I've seen those cups of like you
know plastic couple the lid on it with
like a orange peeled and the wedge is
just thrown into the cup I mean again
common sense that know sometimes it's
asking a lot of people but don't just
assume don't just take it for what
people are na and again question
everything I'm not I'm not here to tell
you this is the only way this is the
absolute best way I'm telling you
challenge me because when you do the
work when you do the research you're
going to realize that everything I'm
telling you is 100% true the more you
lean towards plants the more you're
gonna benefit the more your family's
gonna benefit the more the planet is
gonna benefit the more we're gonna
lessen the suffering of animals it's
gonna be better for your health you're
gonna live a longer healthier life
you're gonna have more energy you're
gonna sleep better you're not gonna be
constipated you're gonna get the right
amount of fiber him you're gonna get the
right amount of protein in you know
you're looking at you know these massive
athletes that are kicking ass doing
their best leaning towards plants and
every day and because I think I'm in a
unique situation because I I'm in a
place where I still speak to a lot of
athletes and I still get to see a lot of
people that are performing at their best
and everyone is everyone is leaning
there isn't a single athlete that I've
spoken to in the past two years that
isn't like yeah you know I'm doing you
know I have athletes that during their
offseason they go really really hardcore
100% whole food plant-based and then
when they're in season they may dabble
because they're on the road or they have
this or they have that but they're
predominantly plant-based yet what's
happening is that most people don't want
to talk about it because then they
become the poster child and they don't
want to become the poster I don't want
that and because the minute they maybe
they change their mind or they do
something different and then they get
attacked I have fish one day and earlier
everybody attacks Boni and they get
attacked and they're like you know what
I'm gonna do me I'm not I don't I don't
need to be that guy I don't need to be
the poster on the side of the bus I'm
cool with it
and it's unfortunate but at the same
time it allows us to look at it from a
different lens and and change the
perspective and say you know what why is
that happening it's happening because we
judge people too much so it was we like
purposely moved away from vegan we
purposely moved away from because we
want people to really feel great about
what they're doing I don't want you to
feel guilt be like people when they're
eating healthier they're like all I
cheated today what was it really a cheat
or was it a treat because if you put the
power in the word that's I mean it's it
can take you in a different direction
you think about a treat you're like I
deserve this man I've run you know 40
miles this week and I've been lifting
for days and whatever you know I biked
150 miles and I felt like I wanted to
have something a little extra and you
did and it was a great treat you think
cheat you're like oh man now tomorrow I
have to do this oh I'm not gonna buy it
on the tone for my sin yeah what is that
right and then you go down that path of
you know destructive behavior and I
think more often than that that's what
winds up happy cuz no one ever really
gains 300 pounds from eating a doughnut
or even eating a box of doughnuts
it's from the behavior that follows
thereafter right that guilt remorse that
sets in that that using yourself self
judgment like oh man
I did it again why did I do that I can't
believe I did that why do I keep doing
this to myself and still just going like
oh well alright
tomorrow's a new day the next meal is a
new opportunity you know to really do it
and right let's just keep it moving let
me dust myself off and then you love
myself no matter what let me keep going
it's really us being so hard on
ourselves that we don't allow ourselves
to really move past it
right right I can't do this I'm a
failure see I told you you wouldn't be
able to do it it's too hard it's too
restrictive one mistake I'm giving up
completely yeah you know when the truth
is if we can be neutral about it go
that's interesting like I planted my
face in the haagen-dazs last night at
midnight I wonder what that was about
like was I feel we did something happen
at work did I have a fight with my
boyfriend or my girlfriend did you no
did I become upset like dude
deconstructing what led you to making
that decision is ultimately the
education and the information required
to know like that signal when it happens
next time to choose a better way it's
part of the process absolutely and I
think that most people think that
success is quite linear uh-huh right and
they look at someone's quickly yeah yeah
it's like boom it's like rich was here
and now all of a sudden he shots the
moon it was it was just a rocket to the
moon and they don't realize that it was
more like look you know hey you know an
EKG graph of course then it was a rocket
to the moon right and and and and it's
not until they realize that there are
ups and downs and there are some
setbacks but as long as you keep moving
in the right direction you're gonna be
okay and that's what this is really
about it's okay man you may think that
it's Jewish strict of today the more you
get used to it the more you start to
change your behavior the more you wire
yourself with new habits you empower
yourself with new habits to be able to
truly live this way that empowers you
that fuels you with health the easier it
becomes it's one day at a time right
it's just every single day trying
because the truth is that we're just a
collection of habits our life is but a
collection habits you sleep on the same
side of the bed every day you wake up
and either brush your teeth before
breakfast or you brush your teeth after
breakfast you don't like oh one day I'm
gonna brush my teeth in the morning the
next day you brush your teeth it always
happens you know
almost always is kind of exactly the
same and if we can find a way to add new
habits so that we can start to change
the behavior because there is no
behavior modification without you
changing your habits right there is no
sustainable change without habits so we
want to make sure that we're we want
people to know that it's not a linear
your graph straight to the moon that it
doesn't happen overnight but did you
have to put the work in to create new
habits to really live this life to
really live the life that you want to
live that your best life because that's
what it is at the end of the day it's
living your best life because if you're
living your best life then you could be
the best friend you could be the best
husband you could be the best dad you
could be the best you know whatever
citizen yeah mastering new habits is the
key to the new life and it does require
a level of discomfort that most people
are afraid of and there are things that
can be done to like mitigate that
discomfort by mastering tiny little you
know changes over time but I would just
encourage people to like embrace that
discomfort and that challenge it's part
of what it means to be human and it's
okay you're not gonna die you may feel a
little weird for a couple weeks at most
but once you master one of those new
habits it becomes wrote in the same way
that you brushing your teeth doesn't
cause you stress or anxiety isn't
something that you do you know both of
us have been plant-based for a very long
time like I really just don't think
about it that much and it's not like
people think oh you're going out of town
oh the planning you must there must be
days of planning trying to get ready for
being in a different city and it's like
no it always works out I know you know
it's like there's a couple things that I
can do it takes no time whatsoever I've
never had a problem it's just not that
big of a deal yeah I I don't think about
it either um you know it's funny because
when you when you look at you know all
of the benefits of a plant-based diet
and then you couple it with intermittent
fasting which we've done and you think
about how much and what and that's one
of the cool things that I love isn't
when you start to think about
intermittent fasting you think about how
much we eat and how often we eat and now
so Marco you're flying from Miami to LA
like what do you
how are you gonna what are you gonna do
it like wouldn't you can't eat the food
on that we're gonna bring with you like
I can't tell you how many times five
hours no that's exactly rows going rich
I can't tell you and I'm sure you see
this right I'm sure you've seen this a
million times like I can't tell you how
many times I jump on an airplane and the
minute the plane takes off people start
to like because they've been conditioned
all right like it could be one in the
afternoon it could be nine o'clock at
night it could be eight o'clock
it could be seven o'clock in the morning
the minute the plane takes off people
want to eat they feel like they have to
be eating cuz it's like they're gonna
die it's like they're on the deserted
island if the food doesn't come fast
enough they start to panic and I'm like
and then and then people ask me like
you're not eating I'm like no that the I
don't know the plane was at whatever 11
o'clock I had breakfast it you know 5:00
in the morning at my house or six or
whatever you know whatever I've I had
breakfast before like I'm good and the
flight attendant like they're so worried
about you some of you argue yeah every
are you sure I can't get you something
are you sure I can and they're so sweet
and they're so kind but the truth is is
that because people panic yeah and I'm
like think about it how often during the
day we're eating and it's like when you
when you eat you have your body has to
digest it so your body's always working
it's always an overtime and I love to
tell my friends like imagine going to
the dealer and picking up like what's
what's the coolest car that you could
think of you want to buy a Ferrari okay
imagine buying a Ferrari turning it on
and then getting in the car and just
playing the foot on the gas lightning
woo
and just leaving it on there forever
like that's art those are our bodies
we're constantly eating and then we have
society telling us oh you gotta eat six
times a day no no you have to eat eight
times a day for your metabolism to be
really revved up what your foot is on
the gas if you don't let that car rest
you're gonna blow that engine out it's
like that's what we do with fasting we
allow the body to do its housekeeping
you just stop eating for 12 hours 14
hours 16 hours whatever amount of time
you want even if it's 10 hours just stop
for a second allow your body to do what
it needs to do to take care of because
imagine if you had someone taking out
you know if you were somebody was
putting a garbage bag in front of you
and you took that garbage bag and walked
it outside to the bin and then came back
inside the house and there was another
garbage bag there and you grabbed it and
you took it back and put it in the bin
and every time you came inside the house
there was another garbage bag there when
would you ever really be able to pick up
the house or take care of any you know
Nick's in the wall or you know scrapes
of paint or pick up the kit you could
never you couldn't ever do anything
except for just grab that garbage and
take it outside because that would
consume all of your time so I'm saying
stop putting the garbage bags there stop
eating for a certain amount of time
every single day and let your body
repair itself it does wonders I'm you I
know you do it I mean it's like how does
it feel it's empowering yes
powering to realize like hey I don't I
don't need to I don't need you first of
all I don't need to be eating as much as
I'm eating I don't need to be eating you
know all day long and then to like feel
better to test yourself in that regard
and and come out the other side actually
feeling better with a little bit more
mental clarity with some enhancements in
your sleep etc I mean downstream there's
all kinds of benefits and the science is
only becoming more and more robust on on
why this is advisable to do but what
does that protocol look like for you
like what is your practice I love to do
minimum minimum 12 hours everyday at the
very least and I shoot for 16 so you
finish you're somebody who probably is
done eating by like 8:00 o'clock latest
right yeah
the latest and I eight o'clock would be
like if I took in sad Friday and
Saturday let's say into consideration as
we went out and we ate something but we
typically eat earlier like you know
whatever yeah 6:30 said then and I also
know no breakfast so then you're not
eating until like 2:00 or 3:00 in the
afternoon the next day if I go sixteen
hours yeah so what I'll do is I'll wake
up and then I'll go to the gym I'll work
out I'll go for a run a lift and then I
come back shower or shave changed or
whatever I have to do go to my office
and then sixteen hours have gone by you
don't have to think of it honestly you
you you think oh my god sixteen hours
without eating you must be starving
yourself by the time you eat you must be
and the exact opposite happens does that
happen to you like you're almost not
hungry you're not going to eat you
you're not hungry
you don't feel like and in the beginning
Marilyn would be like oh my god how are
you gonna do that you're you're probably
gonna wind up losing weight I didn't
lose any weight
everything was fine so I've been fasting
on a regular basis for years and that I
would pick a day of the week or I'd pick
you know a couple days of the month but
it wasn't on a regular basis and then
you know in the last couple of years I
really kind of just kicked it up a
couple knots so it's basically everyday
than your yeah every day so I'll finish
eating at a certain time and I'll wait
at the very least twelve hours but I'm
pushing my standard is fourteen and then
there's some days that I can get to
sixteen if I'm not too busy or not and
what are the positive benefits that
you've experienced just didn't you know
kind of anecdotally with your own eye
you know I've what I've seen in myself
and what I've seen in the you know the
my friends and some of the clients that
I've used it on is that you just feel
this heightened sense of awareness
energy clarity focus you just feel
better you feel lighter your your your
skin starts to feel better you're you
almost feel like any little nagging pain
any little thing that you had going on
that might have been something that you
didn't really put a lot of thought to
but it was kind of there and you just
kind of learn to live with it it's like
you're like oh wait that you know my you
know when I start running my you know
the back of my right you know crest is
not you know kind of ten
anymore for the first 30 steps now I
feel mm-hmm so it's one of those things
where you feel the effects of it
immediately and it's all just like your
body's rested like you're really taking
care of yourself in a good way and then
obviously we've seen all of the science
behind it and you know the the the
benefits on longevity and telomeres and
you know you know kind of turning on
telomerase and all of the stuff that
happens to promote you know sort of
anti-aging if you will inside the body
which is fascinating to me because I we
all want to live forever of course yeah
you know can I had a Valter Longo in
here like so it's pretty nervous work
it's amazing have you tried his fasting
mimicking diet protocol I haven't tried
his protocol I actually was at a can
yeah he did I was at a and I saw Joel
there I was at a convention at an
anti-aging convention in Vegas a couple
of I want to say a couple weeks ago now
it was more than a couple weeks ago I
think it was in December and he was
there he gave a really great talk but I
haven't tried his particular food but
when I think about you know how he put
together that protocol and and what it
entails I mean I do it all the time it's
basically what you're already doing yeah
your version of it yeah so it's my own
sort of 16 our modified fast and then oh
but I do love the science that's coming
out of that space of you know picking
the five days and doing this you know
800 calories or whatnot I love it and I
I can't wait to see more and that the
space is right now exploding so I can to
see I can't wait to see more of that
stuff really come to the surface so as
somebody who's worked with a lot of
people one on one individually over the
years what what is one of our some of
your favorite kind of transformation
stories of people who have really you
know grabbed on to the to the to the
leash and run with it and dramatically
altered how they're living there are a
lot of stories because I mean I've been
in the space for quite some time but I
think my favorite has to be my buddy
Raymond Garcia
you kind of you're uh-huh kind of know
yes I don't know him he was a guy that
with kindness guy nicest guy in the
world absolutely brilliant
we met sort of in the publishing world
he was the publisher to my first boy I
should write published all my books and
I was always kind of just nudging and
for my friends and the people that know
me know that I'm not the kind of person
that is like you know on top of you're
like a drill sergeant every day but I am
like that drop of water on top of the
head every like the Chinese torture like
every time you see me I'm kind of just
like I'll pull you to the side and I'll
say hey you know I think that you really
should consider whatever it is that I
think you you know could use help on and
he was just like morbidly obese and I
was always kind of pushing and nudging
and one day he woke up in the middle of
night with palpitations and he was
sweating he didn't feel good
he was nauseous and he started he went
on his computer he started googling his
symptoms and everything you know what
happens when you google the symptom is
like oh my god like Arnold in the movie
when the kid is like you have a tumor
he's like I don't have a tumor ever you
remember their kindergarten yeah ever
talk yeah there you go and it was kind
of like that he's like oh my god I'm
gonna die I've got you know heart
disease I've got this I've got that he's
just like panicking he's literally like
in a cold sweat
he's nauseous and he's just staring at
the screen calling you in the morning no
no it actually got worse before I got
better and he's like you know oh my god
I can't believe this is happening to me
I can't believe I let this happen to my
life oh how did I do this in now Susie
he was 34 35 like 34 35 and then he six
super successful brilliant guy at the
top of his game but if you saw him you
would be like wow this guy's a bum like
this he's so overweight he sloppy yeah
most people think about people when they
see them so overweight they're like he
doesn't care about himself he doesn't
care about life and this guy's like one
of the most brilliant guys you'll ever
meet and his while he's sitting there
thinking oh my god I can't believe this
his screen just goes to dark cuz he's
not touching the keys anymore
and his screens is planck's out and he
sees in the reflection of the screen his
son walking in the room and it's like
3:00 in the morning and he turns around
really nervous he's like hey buddy and
he's like hey dad are you okay and he's
like man for the first time in my life I
realized that I wasn't okay and I and I
and I felt terrible because I lied to my
son and I said yes I'm okay go back to
bed
and I took him to his room and I put him
to bed the next day he was like that's
it I've got to do something so he goes
he calls his mom and his mom connects
him with the cardiologist who happens to
be the head of Cardiology at Columbia
University and he goes to see him and he
tells amor you've got hypertension too
by the way there is no hypertension
three so if you have a heart attack
you'll probably be dead
you've got pre-diabetes you've got this
you've got this and he just goes on and
he's like here you go and he just writes
some three prescriptions and sends him
on his way and he's just he's imagine
this guy's that's his dirties and he's
like what I was just handed a death
sentence like I got three prescriptions
like oh when does this end like how how
long do I have to take these for
whatever and he had so many questions
for your life yeah exactly
and he goes home and he immediately
calls me and and he's like a super up be
always fun like really joyful guy and
and I can hear in his voice he's like my
phone rings and I see it and I pick it
up I'm like hey what's up man and he's
like do you have a minute
and I'm like yeah are you okay and then
he started to tell me what was going on
and I make me an you're my brother like
do not take those prescriptions and fill
them you're going down the you're gonna
be on the the wrong side of the track
like hold on to them put them in your
dresser drawer today today you need to
start living 100% plant-based not a meal
a day 100% plant-based you need to do
this for the next 22 days and I promise
you you're going to be in such a better
place that you're not even gonna think
about ever filling those prescriptions
and he's something if we had this was an
hour conversation I'm just condensed it
for you not to bore you but somewhere
along the way he was
I'm in I'm in you don't have to tell me
anymore I'm doing this in the first
twenty two days I could tell you that he
lost 22 pounds which he did but in the
first 22 days his hypertension
completely gone he dropped like 30
points in his cholesterol pre-diabetes
no symptoms all of the things that he
was feeling completely gone in
three-and-a-half months almost four
months he lost almost eighty pounds went
back to the doctor again the last time
and the doctor he walks into the room
and the doctors like oh my god those
prescriptions work better than I thought
they would work it's what is and he says
doc I I want to be really honest with
you I never actually filled the first
prescription and he goes you didn't he
said what did you do he says I went a
hundred percent whole food plant-based
diet he says wow isn't that a bit
radical and and and he you know you know
did the blood work and the whole thing
and then realize that he had he had
always had inside of him the power to
make himself feel the way that he wanted
to feel and he was only in a place for a
temporary period of time what happens a
lot of times is that we feel like
because we've gotten to a place that
it's where we belong that we have to be
there that will remain there forever and
we get so lost in the chaos and the
noise and then so scared with what the
potential outcome could be that we are
like oh my god I will take this these
this cocktail of drugs for the rest of
my life and I'll never skip it not
knowing that more often than not it
actually does more harm than it does
good so I was really for me it was
really something that touched me in a
very special place because it mean it's
been five years now or maybe more and
he's kept all the weight off he's still
a hundred percent plant-based that's the
thing the the fact that he's been able
to maintain it and sustain it I know
it's the whole game you know he and he's
are super smart guys so he immediately
was like man I have the keys right in
front of me if I go back to the doctor
with an issue it's only because I no
longer care and take care of myself I no
longer care to do what I need to do and
I'm basically handing over my health or
my life or my lack of health to someone
else but I'm not do
I'm not gonna do it again and again it
wasn't a perfect road for him he
stumbled a couple of times Annie called
me one day I was like man how do you
feel if I you know introduce fish into
my diet on every once in a while I make
me do whatever works for you you've
already seen the outcome of going 100
percent time based now it's up to you
play with it as you yeah do whatever you
think and he'll be the first to tell you
I'm 100% plant-based but if on a you
know occasion I go out to a place and
someone said oh you have to try this
whatever cheese or what have you and he
says I'll try it but for the most part
I'm 100% time-base because I know it was
a duck yeah I know what it does for
myself in his case his change that
change was fueled by a couple things
pain desperation and also on some level
accountability to somebody who knew what
they were talking about yourself right
so he had a little bit of a support
system with you and he had that sense of
desperation that he was at a tipping
point in his life how can we get people
to have that same adoption rate and
sustain it long-term who perhaps aren't
coming from that pain point or are just
like hey man you know I know I can do a
little bit better than I'm doing I mean
I know in the book you've got you've got
the 22 laws 22 laws for the world's most
powerful diet so what it's really
psychology as much as it is anything
else it's not about like here's the
science or the facts of the proof or the
why it's about trying to tap into what
truly motivates people and catalyzes
sustainable behavioral change ultimately
yes that's exactly what it is and and
why I created the book in I broke it
into laws is because again it's the
psychology of it right I wanted to get
to I wanted to help people understand
the different the different ways that
you can think to be able to arm yourself
with the habits to live a healthier
lifestyle you know for example there's a
law that's you know eaten
or way less and there are simple things
that I want people to think about some
of the things you're using a daily basis
some of the vols you'll read once and
you'll never need again because you'll
just get it but eating more weighing
less is is really simple you know
plant-based foods have a much higher
nutrient density and a much lower
caloric density than animal-based foods
so in essence you're gonna eat a lot
more food with fiber because fiber can
only be found in plants not in animals
so you're gonna be full longer you're
gonna be you want to feel satiated but
you're actually gonna be taking in fewer
calories and people get that they're
like oh okay
there's no vegan are not vegan there
it's just simple the more plants you eat
the fuller you're gonna be the more
fiber you're gonna take it the fewer
calories you're gonna take in so if you
want to lose weight if you want to drop
some fat if you want to feel better eat
more plants there's another one
perfection can be the enemy of progress
and that is something that hurts all
many people because we talked about it
right like no one ever gains weight from
eating eight single donut mm-hmm what
happens is that we get into our heads
and it's really about so so to your
point yeah the idea is that it's you're
saying it's somewhat you know psychology
it's almost all psychology because if
you can't get it here though the habits
your wiring or up here you guys you have
to create those habits in your mind to
be able to live this life to be able to
do anything to be able to show up to
work on time to be able to perform at
your best you have to be able to
condition yourself here in order for
this to happen right because this
controls this so if you can give people
these laws to live by I think that once
you understand them you'll be able to
apply them and once you start to apply
them you start to create these habits
that will sustain over time right but
Marco you don't understand my life I got
I got I get up at this time I got to get
my kids to school I got to do this and
I'm barely you know able to pay the
bills as it is what you're talking about
it's gonna take up too much time and
it's gonna be too expensive it not only
is it not more expensive it won't take
up more time so in the beginning you
know it's like a room is a disaster and
you just keep taking clothes off and
piling
and it just keeps piling and piling and
piling and every time you walk in you're
miserable because the room is not the
way that you want it to be that first
time that you have to pick up the room
yeah maybe it takes a little more work
but if you condition yourself to taking
off your clothes and folding it and
putting it away or putting it in the
hamper it will always remain the way you
wanted to so that instead of always
living in that miserable state you're
living in a state of bliss and it's easy
because you've conditioned yourself to
you you've programmed your your habits
your environment your actions to give
you the result that you're looking for
it's not more expensive you and I both
know that I'm tired of hearing people
say that it's more expensive by the way
nothing is more expensive than medicine
nothing
there's Moore's so you're either gonna
give it to Whole Foods or you're gonna
give it to the natural food market or
you're gonna give it to the doctor and
the pharmaceutical companies they say
it's really that simple but it's really
intellectually that makes sense but that
those long-term ramifications are don't
always motivate but what's your radical
than most people what's more expensive
you know every time you you talk to
someone that's eating that still eats
meat they're like no no but mine is
grass-fed and it's massaged and it's you
know that we have or moans and meat is
expensive period when you go to the
grocery store look at it look at how
much fish cost and look at how much
lettuce broccoli beans and quinoa cost
it's a lot cheaper it really is a lot
cheaper now if you want to hold on to
something because we love that white we
love to be able to hold on to excuses so
that you're like wow you know I'm not
gonna start today because I don't have
the money to join a gym I don't have a
chef I don't have okay if you're looking
for excuses you will always have plenty
of them but if you want an opportunity
to live your best life you got to just
jump on it it's on you it's not more
expensive it really isn't you go to
Whole Foods you go to winn-dixie you go
to whatever grocery Kroger any grocery
7-eleven go to any grocery store you
want you compare the price of meat
compared to the price of vegetables it's
not more expensive it just isn't when I
go into that break room though and
there's that box of doughnuts sitting
there mark oh man I just I just can't
help it
yeah you know why are you going into
that break room to begin with right why
are you putting yourself in that
position when you know that there's
nothing good for you there the only joy
that I get all day long then there's a
deeper issue that we need to address but
the reality is you know the there's
there's a great you know amazing work
that has been done in the power of habit
and when you look at the behavior that
got you to the break room and you
analyze it you realize that it really
wasn't the doughnut you were looking for
but rather maybe you were bored or you
wanted just some social interaction or
you just wanted to walk around so you
again you program yourself to understand
that every day at 2:30 3 o'clock when
it's like between lunch and the time for
me to go home I go in that break room
and I just have all the wrong things and
I feel terrible you know after what
maybe it wasn't that you wanted to go
into the break room and have a snack
maybe it's just that you wanted to go
and talk to you know rich down the hall
and you know five cubicles away or you
want her to go downstairs and just get
some fresh air and go outside for a
couple minutes or go outside and call
someone and just say hi to our friend
and catch up with someone for a couple
of minutes because I think that we very
quickly realize that we have will get
that much more joy in doing something
that is good for us and in doing
something that isn't because for the
first three seconds are you eating that
Oreo you feel great
but what happens thereafter right grows
more so you feel like crap you're like
oh I shouldn't have done that why do I
keep doing this to myself but if you
just get up and walk past that you know
break room and you walk down and see you
know mark down the hallway near like
what's up man how are you what do you
you know what's going on what are you up
to you just catch up and shake your legs
out go back to your desk you'll realize
that you accomplished what you needed to
accomplish without feeling like [ __ ]
afterwards we live in very strange
interesting times because all of these
things would have been just a natural
outgrowth of how we live our lives you
know 200 years ago we're moving all day
long or eating food that from the land
that we tilled ourselves we're living in
communities that are closely knit all of
these practices that we're now trying to
get back to that were just part of our
heritage and naturally we didn't have to
try to do any of these things but now we
live in a world of distraction and
dents we're everywhere we look there's
foods that want that are that are
terrible for us that are going to kill
us there are devices that are highly
addictive that are distracting us that
are isolating us that are moving us away
from our communities that are making us
feel lonely and depressed and we have to
actually take we have to really live our
lives with great intention and
discipline and diligence just to take
care of the basic aspects of what it
means to feel grounded and human and
connected and healthy it's weird yeah
it's a it's incredibly weird but at the
same time you know there's been an
explosion in the past hundred years and
technology right which is amazing
because it's provided so much in such a
short period of time like there's been
more growth in less under years and
there were in the last five thousand
right but with that comes a certain
level of responsibility and
understanding that we can't allow the
technology to guide the way we live our
lives we have to use the technology to
live our lives we have to use it to
enhance our lives we can't use it in a
way we can't allow it to to take away
from the quality of life and I think in
many cases because we're not used to so
much technology we allow it to get the
best of us and it's actually not
enhancing your life not making your life
more convenient or more efficient but
actually making it more difficult and
and taking away from the health that
we're looking for so yes you know it's
it's weird but at the same time if you
stop to think about it it's quite simple
right like you don't have to be a victim
of technology technology can help you
yeah but it can also hurt you I mean a
perfect example of that is social right
like you could use social for good or
you could use social for you know for
feeling terrible about yourself I mean
it the choice is yours but the
technology's not going to slow down it's
only gonna keep going faster and in it
it's kind of terrible in a way that
we're getting so much so fast because
we're not used to it and we don't know
how to handle
it but the reality is it's on us like
how it is on us we have to take
responsibility and exercise discretion
and discipline around it or it will
dictate how we live it is dictated yes
so we are living reactively we're taking
our tips about how to live from these
devices and these technologies they're
controlling us
as opposed to us controlling them I
think that's a problem that's only going
to continue to accelerate Oh without a
doubt I mean I think in the next 10
years we're gonna see more than we've
seen in the last 100 years but again
it's it's you know forewarning for
what's coming ahead right so you have to
be we have to live more consciously than
we've ever lived before we have to be we
have to live with more intention that
we've ever lived before I mean I I was
talking to someone a couple days ago and
they showed me an avatar that is I don't
know if you've seen this or if you've
know about this there's like avatars now
that have social pages you were there oh
yeah no I did yeah yeah yeah Japanese
guy who like what is he getting waged -
like a cartoon character and avatar or
something like that no it was like an
avatar that looked like a real human
being that's getting modeling gigs and
his do oh yeah kind of stuff on social
it's kind of my house following I know
aliens of people yeah and it's getting
weird now I told how that's weird right
I'm just saying live in strange times
but we know this right so we have to
live I mean very very consciously we
have to be fully aware of everything we
do on a daily basis and we have to take
the technology and use it to enhance
it's it's it's really that simple I mean
we have four kids as you know and most
of their friends have social pages and
they have devices and they have numbers
and all that stuff and for us it's
really they don't know any better yet so
we have to be those gatekeepers for them
right so we have to make sure that they
know about it and they are exposed to it
and they understand it but it can't
dictate their lives
yeah and I think that we've gotten to a
point where in many cases it dictates
people's lives it and it controls their
emotions on a daily basis yeah every
single second of the
it's controlling kids emotions today
that's really sad where I was I forget
who I was talking to a couple of weeks
ago when we were talking about you know
when we were in school if you had an
issue it was you know from 7 to 2
o'clock in the afternoon and it was done
and you got home and it was cool yeah
now that issues perpetual yeah which is
unfair but we understand that it exists
now so we've got to do something to
either mitigate it to eliminate it or to
learn how to live with it well learning
how to live with it
because when I think of your boys or my
kids you know these are this is being
being skilled in this universe is
important this is the language without a
doubt you know with which we you know
are gonna navigate the world so the
solution isn't to just avoid it
altogether well you have to be fluent in
this language if you're gonna survive
and thrive but it's that balance of
knowing when to put it down and and and
understanding and appreciating the fact
that they are so highly addictive like
you have to respect that fact and not
deny it if you're gonna create kind of
healthy boundaries around it and I say
this is somebody who's has a very
addictive personality and have my own
challenges with creating those
boundaries for myself that's how you
know I'm aware of how powerful this is
and so when I see my daughter's you know
using it it's you know you it's like you
really have to be intentional about it
and you create habits around it I'm sure
you got right like you say okay I'm only
gonna check in at this time and do this
for this period of time and you do it
for a living so it's different for you I
think that for most people but you could
argue that you could really get caught
up in a row yeah because of your
personality because of what you do for a
living and the world that you exist in
right so the relationship that you have
with all of your viewers your listeners
your fans your friends people that love
you is it exists there right so you
can't completely detach yourself from
now but I have to I have to be able to
put it away and I have to actually use
software programs that disconnect my
devices from the internet to prevent
because I don't trust myself as your
great I love that like that's great you
know that's it that's a great way to
program like a you know a habit into
your day that you don't have to think
about I like at a certain time at
whatever seven eight nine o'clock at
night your Wi-Fi goes off right yeah
because it's it goes back to that issue
of living intentionally or living
reactively are you living in defense
mode where you're responding and
reacting to things like a pinball
machine or are you being mindful and
intentional about what it is that you're
trying to create and achieve and that
demands quietude yeah
and that quietude requires that you cut
yourself off from what's really just
distraction and static noise no yeah by
the way I think you've gotten really
really good at that because I've written
you a couple of emails over the past
couple here that I've gotten those quick
responses for hey rich what's up buddy I
was just thinking about you and like I
send and then one second it's like if
you're getting this email I'm buried
under books and trying to catch up to
like 7,000 emails I probably won't get
back to you so good luck peace implants
I turn
I mean email is like I mean I can't even
it might inbox this is Esther and now
text messaging has become the new the
new email and then for my team on the
show we have slack so it's like you're
getting pinged like constantly from all
these different platforms like all day
long and you're you could I can feel my
anxiety like ratchet up and it's like I
got to take control of this no and and
what's worse is that I think people have
become conditioned to because it started
off as something fun like I'm like hey
and I expect you immediately go hey you
know because I either know you got it or
you know I got in it and it creates a
lot of for people creates a lot of
anxiety this is like oh somebody doesn't
get back right back to meeting into it
what happened they read into it I'm like
man just stop it's you know could you I
know mate for a second like believe that
maybe they're busy or they're not
feeling well or they got something going
on or they saw it and they they forgot
how many times is gonna happen that you
open a text message and you're like
about to respond because you you have
the time right that second and then
something happens and you forget
and then you ten more text messages come
in and you don't see that first one that
you opened and it's just it's it's on
it's gone it's gone I just had this
conversation with Julie the other night
I'm like you never did why can't you
mark a text message
unread because I'll read it don't be
like I don't have the answer to that
right now and I don't respond and then
it just 20 more texts come in and I'm
like well that's never good at some sort
Bisou but it's on purpose right so that
we stay connected to it we stay attached
I mean you think they haven't figured
that out and Apple you can on Rita that
I would love to be able to and then and
then you get to the poem you like
scrolling to make sure you didn't forget
and offend someone you know with the
text message it's just it's just too
much right it's just really and then you
can't live your you can't really live
intentionally to your point you like
you're nothing right actively you're not
you're not you can't sit at home with
your kids and you can have dinner with
Julie because you're wondering that I
missed something that I I'll be out
running and then something will ping
into my head like Oh some guy I didn't
text back from like 1012 days ago you
know and then I'll have all this anxiety
like oh my god I can't get back to that
how do you respond like I'm such a
terrible human being
you know no but you know and and I think
that we all have to understand that we
all live in the same space and we're
sharing the same devices and it's about
just again it's about just practicing
kindness like I've I text someone and
they don't text me back oh my god
whatever they're busy is no big deal the
work I think the worst is like whatsapp
because you get to see the the
checkmarks and then people immediately
know that you're online and that you saw
their text message I didn't even know
that yeah and and then it and again it's
that that behavior luckily for me people
know that I'm kind of slow to respond to
texts and well you got to train my own
fault because if you get if you respond
right away to something then you're
creating an expectation that you're the
guy who gets right back to be honest I
haven't done it I haven't I haven't been
that good at doing it on purpose
it really wasn't deliberate it has never
been it's it's kind of just like you
know I'm doing what I'm doing and I'm
always you know I always have something
going on and then I obviously have four
kids and there's just you know only so
many hours in the day and you want to
take care of what you you know what
matters the most and what's really
important you know certain portent you
to disconnect so that you could spend
time with your family the people that
you love because we do all this because
we want to be able to do more of that
right so well on the subject of what
matters most and and what's most
important I want to talk a little bit
about how we scale these ideas that are
in your book and all the work that you
do for the benefit not just of people
who can afford to buy these books or
have the free time to indulge themselves
but for everybody
specifically those that live in food
deserts in urban areas where these ideas
are not part of the daily conversation
where accessibility to organic or
healthy foods is more difficult and
budgets are severely constrained so how
are we going to penetrate the
communities that actually really need to
hear this the most and as somebody who
works with I me work with jay-z and
Beyonce I'm sure you know this is a
conversation you have all the time and
it's it's certainly something that that
I know is important to you and certainly
important to them oh no without a doubt
and for me it's really about it starts
with raising the awareness which I think
we've all done as a collective really
well we're at that point where you know
you're you just witnessed that idea you
know that what used to be the dairy
aisle I don't know what they call it
anymore but that aisle the refrigerated
drink aisle I guess and it's happening
right so I think it's understanding on a
personal level where you are where are
you today and it's really simple you
don't I'd love it if you bought the book
but you don't have to go out and buy the
book right commit to eating one
plant-based meal a day start with one
meal a day one plant-based meal a day
what does that mean what does that mean
Marco it doesn't mean going to a fast
food restaurant or going to an expensive
restaurant in ordering it literally
means exactly that eating one
plant-based meal
what is one plant-based me it could be a
dish with quinoa and some beans and some
steamed broccoli it could be a brown
rice bowl with some sweet potato and
some sprouts over the top but it could
be super super
simple doesn't have to be overly
complicated it's gonna be delicious it's
gonna be satiating but start with one
meal a day if you're living in a food
desert maybe you want to grow your own
food and I know that sounds like a crazy
idea but how important is your health to
you and you have to start there how
important is your health how important
is the health of your family we have to
start somewhere right
and it's unfortunate for some people
that live in you know geographical
locations where there aren't the options
that we may have like here or in Miami
but the reality is we have to surround
ourselves with the tools that we need to
succeed we can't just wait for it to
land on our lap you're not going to just
sit at home and wait until they open a
Whole Foods down the street from your
block if you're waiting for that you may
be waiting a long time so for me it's
really about understanding that it's
really simple
first it's understanding the power that
there isn't a plant-based diet
understanding that there's no right or
wrong way to do it that the more you
lean towards plants the more you're
gonna benefit we've got I think that
we've got that covered I don't think
that there's a question about that
anymore really I truly don't believe
that people are questioning whether or
not a plant-based diet is good for you I
think that people still might question
if it's too restrictive or if it's too
difficult or too expensive and I think
that you and I may have hit on a couple
of points day that might she'll look
shed a little more light today so now
it's about okay how do I put this into
practice start with a meal a day how do
I get that food to start with that meal
a day if you live in a location or in an
area where there's natural markets great
if you live in an area where there's
CSAs or you could belong to some sort of
a co-op where you could get fresh
produce directly from farmers do that if
you are in an area where there are no
farms near you where there are no great
natural food markets near you and the
supermarkets are non-existent then you
may want to consider growing your own
food and it's really not that difficult
or actually growing some stuff at home
now as part of a project for the kids
cool it's really not that difficult then
when you get into it you realize that
there's something profoundly
powerful about understanding what goes
into making the food that you ultimately
eat that goes in your body when you have
that connection with the food you have
such a deeper appreciation and
understanding for what it takes that
you're way more conscious about what
you're going to be putting into your
body not just that day or not just for
that meal but for the future so I think
it there isn't a single solution but I
think that if you look at it and sort of
that frame of mind really understanding
the why and then getting to the how
right and then more importantly
continuing that how by wiring yourself
for the right habits or the right
putting the right laws into practice so
that this is sustainable over time I
think that you have a winning formula
and and and the truth is yes there are
some people that live in in food deserts
but there there are a lot of people that
don't live in food deserts that are
still not living this way that have no
excuse and it might be something it
might be more difficult for some people
and it's unfortunate but it doesn't mean
that it's impossible yeah
budget-wise as well if you just buy a
giant sack of rice and a giant sack of
beans and a giant sack of potatoes
you're 70 percent there and that costs
almost nothing you're done compared to
meat and you were just talking a little
while ago you were playing you know
devil's advocate saying oh it's to
expect you just real and it's not more
expensive it's actually less expensive
and it's better for you not only is it
less expensive now it's gonna be less
expensive to your future self which
isn't gonna require all those
medications so we have this we have
we've we've conditioned ourselves to
doing this you know we love to cook food
with our kids we love to cook with the
kids we love to juice with the kids and
you know the boys are always got their
hands on in everything in the kitchen so
we'll take a couple of days a week that
will make a bunch of stuff and we'll
just put it in the fridge we'll make a
bunch of rice and we'll make a bunch of
quinoa and we chopped up some greens
some greens you can't chop ahead of time
because they started to you know oxidize
but we'll make some beans we'll make
five or six do
types of beans and we just have a bunch
of fresh avocado on the counter and some
tomatoes and whatnot and that's it and
minute we want to eat it's like five
minutes when you have a meal yeah it's
the healthy option is always at arm's
length
since you're never tempted to make an
arrant choice right you don't get home
oh my god I'm dying what do i order a
pizza post mail have it yeah you have it
there it takes it takes longer for
something unhealthy to get to your house
and something super healthy made at home
that you know what's you know exactly
what's gone into it so you have to make
it easy for yourself by putting the work
in the only way to make it easy is if
you put the work in what is the number
one thing you think that that people get
tripped up on not understanding the
power in now I'll start right now the
next meal is your next opportunity to
move in the direction of either health
or disease your next meal what what is
your next meal is of lunch is it dinner
is it breakfast choose wisely that meal
has the opportunity to create a cascade
of effects that will enhance your health
much more than you could ever imagine
but right now is the time there's
something super powerful of right now
and a lot of times with people they get
tripped up on like naina I just need to
learn more I need to do more I need to
really dig into this I need to see the
science I need to see this data it has
to become cool in mainstream meanwhile
they're taking a cocktail of 17 pills a
day we're super something like 4 billion
prescription drugs were four billion
prescriptions were written last year and
that was the equivalent of like you know
I think it was 12 or 13 for every man
woman and child in the United States
crazy it's very similar to to the
parlance of recovery right this idea of
being in the now in a they call it one
day at a time
right so somebody will come in and only
in alcoholic you can say to him
look on the one hand you can like die a
miserable death or end up in jail or
kill somebody or kill yourself or you
can be happy joyous and free like you
just have to do a couple of these things
that are just a little bit inconvenient
what do you want to do and the alcoholic
will be like I need to get back to you
on that right and it's very similar to
this idea of being paralyzed when
presented with the healthy choice versus
continuing to do what you know doesn't
serve you and I think what happens is in
the same way if you tell an alcoholic
look you know just just let your head
hit the pillow tonight without a drink
all you have to do is worry about today
or right now or what are you doing in
the next hour
the alcoholic will say you haven't I'm
going this bachelor party in Vegas and
in three months like there's no way I'm
not gonna be able to drink at that point
you get caught up in this future of that
similarly hey you know just don't like
you know go to McDonald's today like how
about just to eat rice and beans and go
to bed we'll worry about tomorrow
tomorrow yeah but I I'm going to a
wedding in Vegas in three months and
like they're gonna serve this and
they're gonna have cake and I gotta eat
the cake yeah it's like let's deal with
that in three months you don't have to
worry about that right now
the more you can route yourself in the
now what's your next best choice and I
think the important what's been very
helpful to me in in really
conceptualizing that is to understand
something you alluded to earlier which
is there is no stasis we like to think
that things are pretty fixed like I'm
cruising now it's all good like I know
who I am but that is a complete illusion
every choice that you make every
conversation that you have every meal
that you eat anything you take into your
body every idea that you you know foster
in your mind is either moving you in the
direction of becoming a better person or
a healthier person or we're regressing
you back there is no stasis and I think
when you can really connect with that at
least for me that was helpful in helping
me be present for those choices as they
arise yeah and to your point with the
analogy you made about the alcohol
food is the most widely abused addiction
on the planet
absolutely and the worst part of it is
that while a friend would not give you a
drink if he or she knew that you were an
alcoholic I've seen many many many times
where a morbidly obese person is at a
party and an event at a function and
they're handed a cupcake a piece of junk
food that they should not be eating
they're like oh come on it's not gonna
kill you Bert it is gonna kill you
because it's conflated with emotions
like love I care about you I was
thinking about you and that's what makes
it so confusing
but if you're living in the now and you
stop to really think about it do you
really love the person that you're
handing that to if you know that they
suffer from this wretched addiction
that's killing so many people many more
people are dying of heart disease and
they are of you know drug abuse or
alcohol abuse so what is it what is it
that what why is one different than the
other why is it okay to say to someone
that's struggling with their weight and
their health it's okay to have this one
cookie with me and it's not okay it's
taboo to say to someone you would never
say to her friend that was an alcoholic
let's go hang out at the bar and drink
water while I you know do tequila shots
you'd never do Oh Luke forget about that
you never offer them a tequila shot so
why why is one okay and the other one
isn't when the other one is way more
damaging and taking way more lives in
this one so I think we have to stop and
really think about it because you're
like you tell people you have to be in
the present to really enjoy it like you
really have to live in now to enjoy your
life and they think you're living in an
out but they're really not living and
now it's their illusion of them of them
living in the now that is causing them
not to be present in what it is that
they're supposed to be doing sounds kind
of crazy though yeah yeah yeah I mean I
follow you know I I'm with you man I'm
with you so it's like where where do you
start how how you started right
exactly exactly
where do you start it's easy right the
second the next me but I can't do it
right now because I got a I got a you
know I got a meeting tonight and I got
to go do this thing and maybe tomorrow
what's the priority right it's sitting
down and just writing out your goals
your priorities what your part is you
life are how dare you it's you when you
write it down and you're able to
visualize it you can create actionable
steps to get there
if you don't have the discipline to
write them out and to try to create a
hierarchy of priority it would be
impossible for you to achieve that task
I mean you when you're gonna train for a
race you get with your coach you guys
figure out what the training program is
gonna look like you have a protocol for
for how you're going to get where you
want to get you don't just wake up and
say I feel like this okay I'm gonna run
ten miles today and tomorrow I'm gonna
you know do some Olympic lifting and
then the next day I'm gonna swim it
doesn't happen that way there has to be
some sort of order and structure for you
to achieve your goal in the most
efficient manner because you could argue
that maybe you could get there but it
won't be as efficient as it could have
been or as enjoyable as it could have
been if you had done it the right way
and I in it in the right way is really
what matters most to you you are okay
you have a meeting tonight and you can't
start today no problem so when can you
start and then when you start that
conversation you really start to think
about it you're like how many times
haven't I spoken to someone that says to
me yeah I want to start but man I've got
a trip next week and oh I my birthday's
coming up and I don't want to commit to
something just to break it for my
birthday and I don't want to there's
always called the lies common thing it's
called life life is fluid it's not ever
gonna line up so now these things
convenient for oh my god
I can't believe it I'm listening to this
podcast and I just happen to be starting
on my vacation tomorrow and by the way I
just inherited $15,000 and I just moved
one block away from a wholefoods that's
not gonna happen right if you're
listening and that just happened to you
but the truth is it more likely than not
it's not it's not reality you have to
make it work we all have to make it work
for ourselves and you know some things
might be easier than others but you have
to just figure out what's most important
to you and just go after it right and
and going after it means like taking
that first step that that first step is
the most important them the most
important thing to it's the only thing
there is because without the first step
there is no second step right so you ask
me what's the most powerful thing it's
now powerful Marco Borges thank you very
green print so in addition to the book
which is amazing it's beautiful - you
guys do an incredible job
it's gonna help a lot of people it's
super powerful and what's great about it
also is it's just it's so accessible
it's you can read it you can completely
understand you can open it up to the
middle to the recipes or whatever and
it's just it's very to-the-point and
it's very it's just it's just digestible
right you can read it you get it you're
like okay I'm on board but in addition
to the book you also have some other
stuff coming soon right can you talk
about that yeah there's some fun stuff
coming why we can't talk about most of
it we have this tool that we're about to
drop that I think people are gonna be
really excited to see because it'll
allow you to really visualize the impact
that your daily choices have not just on
you but on the planet and I think that
the more we get people to really
understand about you know how this small
little thing affects everything the
microcosm impacts the macrocosm yes yes
and vice versa
yes it's all connected we're all living
on this planet together we're all in
this together your success is my success
my success is your success
and the more that we can evolve out of
our perspective our zero-sum game
perspective I think we'll all be happier
and more content and more productive and
more cooperative I couldn't agree more
yeah your your success has nothing to do
with my level of success if anything
your success begets more success for me
without a doubt mmm it's a perpetual
motion and is there well there's a
Lissa's kind of out right like you have
there's a documentary that you guys are
working on yeah can you talk about that
or no I mean there I say that only
because I saw a couple articles about it
yeah so we we have throughout this
processes we're creating the green print
we realized that there was this amazing
opportunity but also more importantly
responsibility to share it with the
people that need it the most through
their lens and we were we we did a I
don't know if I were sure that when you
say we is that you jay-z and Beyonce or
a-team yeah behind you exactly so we
decided that we that we wanted to not
just share the information be sure to
share it in a manner that that really
spoke to the people that needed it the
most because they are yes there's plenty
of people who are living in food deserts
and there's plenty of people that live
in inner cities that have you know 15
liquor stores in a three-block radius
but have no natural food markets and
that have little bodegas with you know a
bunch of packaged potato chips canned
goods but have no health food whatsoever
and there's something there's something
wrong with the system right there's
something really wrong with a system
that in many areas is set to lead people
down the path of failure and we have to
change that and and it's not until we
all understand that we are all part of
it that we can change it together and
that it affects each and every one of us
that it that it won't change so for us
it really was about okay understanding
that it started with something as simple
as like I want people to know that
every time they eat they're making a
decision that has profound effects not
just under health but on the health of
the planet but there are some people
whose decisions are more difficult than
yours and when we started to have that
conversation it was right around the
time where we're doing our clinical
trial with Holy Name hospital in New
Jersey and I don't know if I shared that
with you or we where we took a cohort of
300 people and we we actually took a
group of 300 people split them into
three cohorts where we had a vegetarian
group standard American diet and a vegan
cohort and and the benefits of a 100%
plant-based diet over the course of 22
days 60 days 90 days were so vast that
we had to almost eliminate the standard
American diet from the control and and
and and base our results on the
comparison between a vegan diet and a
vegetarian diet I mean just just in LDL
which is your most dangerous cholesterol
in 22 days we saw reductions of 40% Wow
comparing the vegetarians of the vegans
we already eliminated the meat so it was
such an eye-opener for so many people in
the medical community that we decided if
these people don't know about this what
are the people that are living in the
inner cities thinking how are they going
to be able to help themselves if when
they lean into an establishment that is
supposed to help they don't get the help
that they need or the information that
they need to be able to move in the
right direction when we saw that we
realized that there was an opportunity
for us that was you know far greater
than just writing a book it was really a
responsibility to share the information
with as many people as possible through
the medium of a book and through the
medium of a documentary so we started
filming the documentary middle up
towards the end of last year and we'll
do it through this year and will
hopefully bring it
I would con next year oh cool yeah we'll
see how that does how the process goes
you know it's a it's a long journey
there long but long but it's a but it's
a really I think it's really needed from
this perspective because when you have a
conversation with someone about eating
healthier and you're standing inside a
Whole Foods you're missing a big pick a
big part of the picture right so it's no
it's no longer about just telling people
- what is it is it organic broccolini or
conventional broccolini while you're
standing instead of Whole Foods when
someone's never seen a Whole Foods in
their entire lives
so it's really about getting to the core
of the problem and then trying to solve
the problem from that point this is the
most important thing democratizing not
just access but education around these
ideas and that's what we're joined you
yeah the market results that's a
beautiful goal my friend thank you
well cool doing you I think we did it
how do you feel this is I think this is
the best cast that we've done how many
we've done like four of these right I
don't know it's three this is how
amazing thank you thanks for the
opportunity I appreciate it I appreciate
you thank you for all the amazing work
that you're doing and you continue to do
how things every time I talk to someone
they're like I love rich Rahl I'm I
can't tell you how many people I meet
that tell me they met me through rich
roll I'm like how so they're like oh I
heard you wanna show her which is
amazing so thank you thanks for all the
well doing and I really appreciate it
thank you for saying that I will receive
that that's one of my things for 2019 to
be able to like because I normally like
I deflect or I minimize and it's like I
will receive that you are amazing [ __ ]
you are amazing and you're inspiring so
many people I mean you cannot even begin
to imagine the amount of people that you
inspire on a daily basis I told you I'm
to drive up where I was texting with
Michael and he says oh my god I love
rich Tom I said what's up tell him I
love him yeah I mean every time I come
into contact with someone that is
dabbling or is 100% onboard I can tell
you that nine out of ten times it's
because of something that you've done
that if it's that has inspired them
directly to want to take control of
their lives and that is something that
you should not take lightly because a
lot of people owe their lives in their
health to the work that you're doing so
thank you man
really cool thank you now I'm getting
uncomfortable but I will receive that
receive it yeah we love you man I love
you man
so much you are a force for good and
much needed in this world I love your
positive energy
III I think of you as a mentor not just
in business but in life and in parenting
how you conduct yourself in your public
life and your personal life is inspiring
to me as an parents and and as a family
man like you're just beautiful through
and through and I wish you only the best
and the most success in this this this
mission this laudable mission that we're
both on so thank you for sharing with me
today let's keep having fun yeah cool
pick up green print available wherever
you buy books keep an eye out for the
documentary and we don't even talk about
what's going on with 22 days we're
having fun yeah you know trying to
provide products that people needs and
keep moving in the right direction we'll
do it yeah we're not doing it in the
conventional cpg way we're not we're not
the traditional consumer packaged goods
company we want to and it's kind of
crazy because when I created it you know
it was really about creating a platform
to help people to to inspire people
that's a product hierarchy just kind of
secondary to this being more of a
Content play and an education yes yes
and but I mean obviously we are a
business yeah but I mean I think I don't
I don't need to tell you you know where
my heart's at I'm you know I just want
to help people live a healthier life and
if someone is on the other end listening
to this and they're now inspired to go
have a healthier you know meal the next
meal that they eat I'm elated
I just makes my heart shine because
that's at the other day that's what I do
it for I want people to really live
their best lives because I love life I
love people I love being around you know
I was having a conversation with a
friend a few weeks ago there's like you
really would want to be to live 200
years we're talking about other guys in
Silicon Valley that are saying they're
gonna live to be 200 but but you know I
would I would love to stick around as
long as possible are you kidding me I
want to be around to see my kids grow
really old and be really happy and have
amazing families and
I just love living there's nothing wrong
with that there's nothing wrong with
being around forever I mean if I could
do it I absolutely would do it my
friends like now I do get bored there
would be no reason to live I'm like nope
speak for yourself buddy I want to be
her forever so you know so yeah back to
22 days it's it's really about
continuing to provide products that
inspire people that move people and
again always being as clean as possible
right for us it's a commitment to you
know always being plant-based always
being organic always being non-gmo and
and making products that that help
people not just formulating for fad
formulating for label copy wow that
doesn't interest me whatsoever I'm not
formula reverse engineering to get to a
certain margin and you know people look
at me like I'm absolutely nuts because I
do what no one else in this space does
but for me it's really important that I
make products that are good for people
that are truly good for people that are
game-changers you know that that that
feel good for me to know that my friends
are consuming them not be like whoops
like okay you know I want to be proud of
it you know my kids go home and then
make shakes and they're like all we just
made this amazing shake after you know
they're playing a lot of tennis not on
which other I'll share with you later
but um you know after their workouts or
making smoothies at home and I just feel
great about it you know it's just feels
so good knowing that they're putting the
absolute best possible foods into their
body there's it's just priceless
yeah that's great well you know I'm a
huge fan it's the only product line that
I use in terms of supplement powders and
the like and the bars are fantastic next
name as somebody who spent a lot of time
training and has eaten a lot of bars
over the years most far I just can't eat
I can't do it anymore he's like no more
bars but your bars are super tasty
thanks my love them and super nutritious
too so fantastic if people are listening
to this and they want to connect with
you what's the best place or way for
them to do that 22 days nutrition calm
or our Instagram is 22 days of nutrition
across all social so we're pretty quick
to respond except if you text me are you
doing a public speaking stuff around
print and yeah we've been and are you
doing tons of press right I'm doing a
yeah a couple of weeks of touring for
the book and then we're gonna do some
stuff back in Miami that will be back
here and to do some things we'll do
something in New York so we'll keep you
posted
yeah it's on the website where if people
want it if it's public and people want
to come out and yes you go to 22 days
nutrition com4 slash book you'll you'll
get all the info there and update you on
what's going on and where we are where
we're gonna be awesome
thanks man how you shoot you feel good
easy absolutely amazing thank you all
right well come back and talk to me
anytime thank you I appreciate that
much love peace of your men plants
[Music]